Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
in my Arrow and Flash videos I asked you to
submit all your questions about the new seasons
so I picked 10 of them to answer and one bonus
question.
Since yesterday we also got a much longer
extended trailer for The Flash, so I’ll
mention the new stuff we learned.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I’m going to be doing Arrow and Flash videos
every week until the new seasons premiere.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
leave me suggestions for bonus videos.
So let’s pick apart the new footage from
The Flash.
Most of the stuff we saw we already knew about.
The Costume being from Star Labs, his inner
circle of Caitlin and Cisco.
Tom Cavanagh looks like he’s going to be
their version of Feliticy, the tech person.
Which I think is funny.
I loved the way Star Labs looks.
It seems like they’re going to have a secret
or special area inside the facility that they’ll
use as their version of the Arrow Cave.
The big news is Weather Wizard.
He’s going to be the first villain and the
first Rogue on the show.
What is seems like they’re doing is combining
aspects of the New 52 versions of the characters
and the classic Flash Rebirth story.
In the classic Flash stories, the rogues aren’t
meta-humans.
They just have technology that gives them
their powers.
In the new 52 comics, they all get exposed
to a special Star Labs device that gives them
real powers.
It seems like some or all of the villains
on the show will have real powers.
Based on the particle accelerator causing
all the weird energy to spill into their dimension.
I loved the way Weather Wizards powers looked
on the show.
I think the special effects are great.
Zoom as a villain was confirmed.
It’s pretty clear he was the one who killed
Barry’s mother.
We can unpack that in the comments for people
who don’t know that story from the comics.
The show itself is premiering in October at
the same time as Arrow Season 3.
It’s going to be on Tuesday Nights at 8PM
and Arrow will still be on Wednesdays at 8.
Which means it will be way easier for me to
do videos for both of them, yay.
Also it was confirmed at the upfronts that
Malcolm Merlyn would be a cast regular.
Meaning he’d be in most of the episodes.
Not necessarily as the main villain, but as
his antagonistic self.
So he’s probably going to cause trouble
for Team Arrow even if he’s not the big
bad.
Time to answer some questions though.
Careful for spoilers from the Arrow Finale
if you haven’t seen it yet.
Here we go Question 1 - Adri on Facebook asks
Andrew Kriesberg said one of the main cast
members would not be starting Season 3.
Who do you think it is?
It’s probably Paul Blackthorne, Detective
Lance.
He was at the CW Upfronts, which means he’s
still part of Season 3, so he’s not dying
or anything.
He just sustained internal injuries during
that Police Station fight.
He might go into a coma or just sit out a
few episodes on ‘medical leave’ or something
like that.
But he’ll be back!
Question 2 - Niels asks Could Edward Fryers
from Season 1 on the Island have been hired
by Amanda Waller?
Yes it’s possible but they’d have to mess
with a few things.
Edward Fryers was going to use weapons to
destabilize the Chinese Hong Kong situation.
The lady in the red shoes in that scenario
did not look black.
But Amanda Waller was operating in Hong Kong
around that time.
They cast Amanda Waller during season 2, so
it’s possible they could retcon that woman
in red shoes to be Amanda Waller.
They retconned Sara Lance when they cast Caity
Lotz.
The other possibility is that it’s someone
from HIVE.
I know a lot of people thought it might be
Isabel Rochev, but she didn’t seem powerful
enough five years ago to pull off an operation
that big.
Question 3 - DigiDestined asks what was happening
in that scene after Oliver left the island?
So the Amazo boat blows up and Oliver wakes
up in Hong Kong with Amanda Waller inducting
him into service.
It looks like he worked with her and then
ended up back on the island at some point.
In the pilot episode he seemed much more cool
and level headed.
But that mega beard makes me think he was
stranded.
So clearly he went on missions for ARGUS in
the five years he was away, then something
went bad and he ended up stranded back on
the island before coming back to Starling.
The interesting thing is that the show always
goes back to the Island.
Because it’s purgatory it’s this metaphor
for Oliver’s life as well as his hero’s
journey.
For all you Joseph Campbell Geeks.
It’s the transitory state between Justice
League and his old life.
So until he either dies or the show reaches
that Justice League moment, he’s always
going to go back there.
So there will still be island scenes in season
3.
Question 4 - McLovin asks Will Team Arrow
and Team Flash ever combine forces to fight
a single villain?
Yes, they can’t have their schwarma Avengers
crossover moment until they defeat some common
enemy.
Oliver isn’t going to drop in to just say
high.
Whenever they go on each other’s shows it
will be because there’s a problem in Central
City that only Oliver and Felicity can solve
and vice versa on Arrow.
As for who that villain is?
It will depend on who the other big villains
both shows bring on.
Zoom is the big bad on The Flash, so there’s
the possibility Team Arrow could help Barry
with that.
Or Felicity could help him with his Mother’s
murder.
Her skills are very CSI friendly.
Whenever everyone goes to comic con this summer
they’ll also probably talk about what the
crossovers will be like..
Question 5 - Peacekeeperboy asks Who do you
think is going to be the main villain next
season and how many episodes of the Flash
will there be?
Just talking about the Flash, Zoom will always
be the main villain.
But there’s always a big villain that works
for the main villain.
So it might secretly be Tom Cavanagh’s character.
Like a wolf in sheep’s clothing kind of
thing.
Or it could be one of the Rogues like Captain
Cold.
My money is on one of the Rogues.
If not all of them.
I think we’ll get to see the Rogues unite
during season 1.
We saw Weather Wizard in the trailer.
As for episodes.
They haven’t said officially, but the show
has at least 8 or 9 episodes.
If they get picked up for the second half
they’ll at least get a full 22.
Arrow on the other hand usually gets 23 episodes.
Which is a lot.
Most shows only get 20 or 22.
At the upfronts, the CW was saying that The
Flash is the one show they are sure is going
to be a hit.
So all of their energy is going into promoting
it as the Flagship of all their new shows.
Question 6 - magnettoa Which villains do you
think we’ll see on the Flash?
I think they’ll stick to core rogues in
season 1 with maybe a curveball or two.
I think there will be at least one surprise.
Like someone that Arrow shares in common.
Someone we’ve already heard about on Arrow.
Like HIVE.
As for Weather Wizard in the trailer.
If you’re not familiar.
In the pre-new 52 comics.
He used a Weather Control Rod to control the
Weather.
Like he was just a regular guy with technology.
In the new 52 comics and on the show he’s
a meta-human with real superpowers that enable
him to control weather.
It looks like he’s mostly going to be generating
tornadoes.
Based on those last moments in the trailer
it seems like in defeating Weather Wizard’s
tornado, Barry is going to learn that there
are levels of speed he can achieve.
The speedforce isn’t like stop and go.
It’s like internet bandwidth.
If you have internet at your house.
It moves slower when a bunch of people are
downloading stuff at once.
But when it’s just once person downloading
it’s way faster.
So the more Flashes that are in one place
accessing the speed force, the slower Barry
can run.
Because we know Zoom is Edward Thawne and
he works with Barry you’ve got two people
drinking from the fountain.
Plus if John Wesley Shipp ends up being Jay
Garrick, you’ve got a third Flash.
In the comics, when Barry is the only one
accessing the speed force, he can run so fast
that he can go forwards and backwards in time.
So him trying to run back in time and prevent
his mother’s murder might be a thing this
season.
I think it will take most of the season for
him to figure out the speed force though.
So don’t plan on time travel any time soon.
This is mostly going to be superhero CSI.
Question 7 - Michelle asks What do you think
Felicity’s backstory is going to be?
Yes, we’re supposed to get a lot more Felicity
backstory in Season 3.
I think they might invoke some of the Firestorm
aspects of her character from the comics.
In the comics the Ronnie Raymond version of
Firestorm is part of Firestorm.
So they might make her father part of that
mythos.
Like make her father the Professor Martin
Stein part of the character.
It’s a little far fetched, but I think it
would be so cool.
There’s also the possibility that they could
change all that and make her Father part of
HIVE.
Usually when people in comic book shows don’t
like to talk about their parents a lot it’s
because something really awful happened to
them, like they were fused with the Firestorm
Matrix.
Or they did something really awful.
A la villains.
Question 8 - Neto del Toro asks Do you think
Oliver knows about Connor?
I don’t think he knows.
It think they would be trolling us the fans
too much if Oliver always knew everything
and just never told Team Arrow.
Like when he had a vial of the cure this season
and just hadn’t told any of the Team about
it.
He had the cure the whole season and he waited
six months to tell them.
That made me kind of mad.
So I don’t think he’d turn around and
do the exact same thing.
But I do think he’ll try to keep his distance
just so his son can stay safe.
Remember that speech he gave Felicity about
not keeping the ones you love too close.
That was in the first couple of episodes.
Question 9 - Green Quiver asks, could Thea
become Cheshire?
Totally, I saw a bunch of you commenting on
how she looks a lot more like Chesire in the
comics than Artemis.
And remember, regardless of who is what in
the comics, they can give any minor super
hero persona to any of the characters.
So even though Artemis in the comics is the
daughter of Sportsmaster, Thea on the show
could still become her.
Regardless, she’s going to be more like
the Canary when we see her again.
She’s going to be a much bigger badass.
I can’t wait to see her and Roy have a big
fight scene.
Or her and Oliver.
Question 10 - Jean Loup asks Will HIVE come
back?
Even if HIVE isn’t the main villain or group
of villains in season 3, they teased them
as a pretty big thing this year.
So we’ll at least get to learn more about
them.
They’ll just be like an evil version of
ARGUS.
Don’t be surprised if Merlyn gets mixed
up with them.
Remember, he lost his company and all his
money like Oliver.
So where did he get that limo at the end?
He’s got to be getting money from somewhere.
Bonus Question - Iron Guardian asks do you
think The Flash will have Flashbacks like
Arrow or be more like CSI with mystery solving
side quests?
They cast Barry’s mother, so there will
be some flashbacks.
That murder mystery will probably tie into
the finale.
But in terms of daily flashbacks, I think
we’ll see more cut-to’s.
Like the murder mystery investigation will
be going on off in the background of each
episode.
So think of it more like an episode of Bones
with superpowers.
He’ll be using his abilities and Star Labs
to connect crime scenes to the particle accelerator
explosion and metahumans.
So thank you so much for submitting questions.
These are always a ton of fun to do.
Because both shows are on different days I’ll
be doing separate videos for each.
But in the meantime I’ll probably just use
wednesdays for Arrow and Flash bonus videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
let me know what you guys want to talk about
first.
Also, let me know if you want me to keep doing
Q&A videos once a week.
I’ll probably just combine Flash and Arrow
questions based on the bonus videos I do.
Right now click here for my Arrow Finale video
and click here to learn about my top 5 flash
villains.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!